there's no way you could love me when
you're done another [ __ ] you love them
and I'm in the bed with you Michael was
the woman that you left the message for
an American
yes yes this Michael has Bamboozled us
for too long and I knew it I knew it I
didn't want to believe it but deep down
I knew he was not as innocent as he
seemed not only has Michael been
cheating on Angela but he's been
cheating on her with another American
Woman
I think that's some [ __ ] he wrote a text
that could get us in so much trouble
like let me get to the states and I'll
come to you I'll handle Angie he wrote
that being a Nigerian he knows better he
wrote that on paper on text I know there
are some of you who are probably
thinking I always knew he was a Yahoo
boy I was thinking from the beginning he
was looking for a bad Visa
well now it's pretty much clear
Michael you can suck your teeth all you
want to you're wrong
like a little [ __ ] okay okay
him
yeah Michael has turned into a villain
and the cast does not hold back let's
get into it
hey 90 day fans fam it's melissia I've
missed you Happy New Year I hope you're
doing well before we get into the
details of Michael's Affair being
exposed in part two of the tell-all I
want to quickly catch you up on what you
might have missed in part one some
shocking but good news Bilal is now
ready to have a child with shaida we
started to use
um no protection or anything like that
whoa okay this is breaking news shy
I mean then started to try time to try
like we tried a couple of times but it
looks like in part three that shot is
going to reveal that she actually put a
pause on them trying so Bilal you want
to have a baby now and shaida you want
to put off having a baby they have
reasons what caused my change of mind
but I guess we'll get into that later on
now let tell me now after everything
shaida all I can think is girl you
better be sure because now it's on you
that's interesting though how you could
want something so bad when it seems Out
Of Reach but the moment it becomes
available you start thinking twice
I can't wait to see what she has to say
next up Usman and Kim have not gotten
back together oh thank God yes they say
they are not done they are done done
there's a difference
done and over
but we're friends but we're cool so
and I told him we could just be friends
with benefits I'm good with that oh no
Kim let's not act like that's gonna work
majority of the time doing something
like that with your ex is a setup for
heartbreak again
let's keep running with the momentum you
have never look back never speaking of
Usman he and Angela have beef
she explained how it all started ahead
of traveling to New York for this hello
yes
about me all over social media and my
husband didn't take up for me then you
got his girlfriend I had no problems
with her but if she says one damn word
out the way you already know
you already know so the best thing can
be late can say nothing
and let me and who's been taking them
because I'm not taking it either
the last time I spoke to Usman I told
him exactly how I felt I thought he was
a scammer and I still do
shout she was saying that man's name at
all
I had to take some time to get it right
too but dang and Kimberley
Angela
anyway once she gets to New York she's
in the hotel a little turn and she goes
into a dance break I guess she was
feeling herself
I love it oh I love you
[Music]
welcome
she is such a mood have y'all seen that
video of Angela turning up in New
Orleans can't stop won't stop get guap
10 white toes and them toy flip-flops
many kids and pedicures I'm always Tip
Top when they say I'm not hot all these
lies need to stop cause I'm icy wifey
haters want to fight me she started
climbing the pole the first time I saw
that video it gave me a good laugh you
couldn't tell Angela nothing
all right back to the tell-all once
Angela gets to set the next day she
sprayed her holy water before she went
on stage
Lord if I don't need you today holy war
all right
but once she got out there that holy
water went out the window and all hell
broke loose hey Michael
look who's here that lying son of a
[ __ ] ain't gonna be good
I don't have nothing to do with this I
hope not Kim because I have nothing
wrong with you so keep me out of it it's
not gonna be good stupid ass Shut up up
here you go already
who the [ __ ] you think is scared of you
Kim attempted to calm things down
didn't work
again I just left my job
and then Yara looking so cute tried to
stand up to Angela although she admitted
she was scared of her earlier in the
episode of course I don't want for
Angela Johnson beat me or something
that's the only thing I'm nervous about
so but I'm nervous I just fixed my boobs
I don't want for she like a jump on me
and Destroy them shield down the respect
us please Yara shut up you have no you
don't
understand
yeah Sean didn't even introduce everyone
yet and they were already over Angela
Usman called her a pig
and she stormed off
Angela Bing Angela but all of this
brings us to part two Michael and his
confessions
[Music]
Angela goes out and takes a smoke break
and then makes her way back to set
hi Angela hello Sean how are you
once she sits Angela acknowledges her
behavior was out of line you know I'm
the first one to meet when I'm wrong
when I'm wrong and wrong obviously I was
wrong and then they start to discuss the
fact that Angela caught Michael cheating
on her remember during the season finale
she broke down in tears about it
my friend sent me
the receipts
Texas y'all know what she means Michael
cheating on me
I didn't believe it at first
but then I got a voice note
I got him right here
okay
I will let you know okay I'll call you
please I love you honey I miss you I
guess Michael is shaking his head at his
own behavior of course the cast reacts I
love you can you believe you said that
to this girl that's how you talk to me
I don't want to believe it but there's
no way there's no way to defend him
oh my God
Angela breaks down in tears once again
The Voice
the voice note oh she is in pain y'all
heard that cry
the singer in The Voice
the voice note Angela puts on this tough
exterior but in moments like this you
can see that little girl inside of her
Angie Angie it's okay please it's not
okay Michael you're alive son of a [ __ ]
I protected you for four years did I
know you're just stupid but when you do
that right there there's no way you
could love me when you're done another
[ __ ] you love them when I'm in the bed
with you you don't want me to believe
you love me
why do you keep saying it's okay though
is that really okay
you don't say okay bro you say sorry
that is why you should come out from
your mouth not okay
this man needs to take his own advice
and look at Michael looking pitiful
you did it
okay yes this random uh ladies
all this I I know are admitted my home I
caused it all you know well for the fact
that I I did this I see I love my wife
and nobody can come in between us I
don't think Michael has ever been in the
hot seat like this during a tell-all
just a refresher this woman that he
cheated on Angela with is supposedly 31
and they met on Instagram now we learned
these details during the season finale
it wasn't a huge shock to me it was a
shock but it wasn't a huge shock yes
cheating is wrong at the same time
Angela talks to Michael the way you
would talk to your worst enemy so I was
like okay he cheated with this young
woman I started to imagine her and I
assumed she was Nigerian but lo and
behold this woman is from America I said
oh he is out here creating backup plans
to get to the States but he did just
call her random so I'm not sure how
she's going to feel about that
[Music]
yes yes this is America America
I was thinking from the beginning he was
looking for that reason
I am just being polite I don't like
ignoring people you know Michael is not
built for the cheating life he doesn't
even know how to lie that's both that's
not being polite
I went too too far about it which I I
truly admitted
my God I know
Angela you said he left that message for
this woman while he was with you yes how
do you know that because I all the dates
the times yes she sent she sent it to a
friend of mine y'all I would not be
surprised if this mystery woman is one
of Angela's friends
don't act like people don't do that
message him and see if he'll message you
back it could be Renee she was at the
tell-all or it could be another one of
Angela's friends
I hope Angela didn't go that far but I'm
just saying I wouldn't be surprised
the friend probably waited to tell
Angela about these messages when she got
back to the Saints so she wouldn't end
up in jail in Nigeria for going
ballistic or Michael
okay let me stop I'm just joking
just a theory
just imagine if your friend would not
have sent these to you this would have
been going on
and he lies so bad he needs help
if the way Angela says things sometimes
it could be a serious moment but you
can't help but laugh Angela goes on to
reveal that even though Michael cheated
they are still together
and I don't see why after he did what
she says next
he wrote a text that could get us in so
much trouble
like let me get to the states and I'll
come to you I'll handle Angie he wrote
that being a Nigerian he knows better he
wrote that on paper on text Michael is
that true
yes
but I I look down down box I never
mentioned I I told my wife I said
Kim wasn't hearing anything Michael was
saying and she gave him a piece of her
mind just cheap and stuff I'm telling
you and using the scamming word I'm
telling you y'all are something
Michael you can suck your teeth all you
want to you're wrong
like a little [ __ ]
Kim said his wife calls him that so I
guess I can call him that too
Shawn then tells Angela who was unaware
that Michael is back on Instagram now we
start yeah some some blogger posted it
yeah I was actually watching that same
account I sent it to Usman no no
yes yes no you're no not
no no I'm not it's not me Michael cannot
keep this little smirk off his face he
claims it's an imposter but Angela not
knowing what to believe makes a good
point this could all be a part of his
plan he wants her to think it's an
imposter when it's really him oof the
moment you can't believe anything that
comes out of your partner's mouth
I think that's a good time to leave they
don't say trust is the foundation of a
relationship for no reason
is it funny why are you smiling it looks
like Michael continues to lie when Sean
asked him if he sent money to the other
woman he can't help but smile why are
you smiling I did no the question is
just alarming I didn't send money to
life do you have a separate bank account
that Angela does not know about oh my
God
no no I no I can't no no I can't
you have no other baby wow Michael and
guess what apparently he asked this
woman to come see him on Valentine's Day
instead of Angela she in the white for
Valentine's Day yes to Nigeria for
Valentine's Day
instead of his wife yeah well she didn't
come back
you're a married man you shouldn't have
invited her Angela then has one of
Michael's uncles one she somehow managed
to keep a good relationship with come on
the show and he condemns Michael's
cheating calling it a sinful act and an
Abomination I will do my best on behalf
of the family
to resolve this conflict oh goodness
that sounds uh menacing what what are
you going to do Stephen what do you uh
how do you help get this relationship
back on track I would let other members
of the family knows I will teach
it's our culture to allow the Elder to
talk to the young ones time to talk to I
need to make it an other member of the
family will talk to him too
I know you're listening
fast forward they will play Angela
attacking Michael in Nigeria and Sean
asked the rest of the cast The Golden
question is there anybody here who
believes that Angela's Behavior over
time
keywords over time may have contributed
to the breakdown of this relationship to
the point where Michael was seeking love
elsewhere
no no
but in the same time she was really like
bullied to him she was not nice to him
for a long time yes doesn't mean that he
did something good he did wrong for sure
wrong but I think that's not how people
should handle it yeah maybe no maybe I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna say so much
bullying because that's kind of a look
it's not an appropriate words that's
what's been using bullying it's kind of
strong what happened was kind of strong
Renee I agree with Yara Michael is
completely wrong he is married at the
same time Angela's Behavior toward him
over the years has been horrible
just the way she talks to him y'all
remember this you're an ugly son of a
[ __ ] son of a [ __ ] son of a [ __ ]
I was always taught make your man feel
like a king lift him up so even if he
thinks about cheating he'll consider
that he has something good at home that
he doesn't want to mess up now that
being said there are some men out there
who are just going to do what they want
to do regardless of how good you are but
that's beside the point I just don't see
how someone would desire to be loyal to
someone who speaks to them in such a
degrading way
at the same time the way it's looking
now Michael has been scamming Angela
it's just all the scalding hot mess I
would love to know what you think do you
believe that Angela's Behavior over time
contributed to the breakdown of this
relationship or is Michael just a
scammer and that settles it
let me know in the comments
he's called Shawnee don't know the
effect of my whole family
it is
so easy
You're Not Sorry Michael you're sorry
you got caught
[Music]
like this
my grandkids don't see me cry my kids
what you did to me
oh she doesn't cry
makes sense she might need to cry more
often let some of that energy out
Angela and Michael's segment ends with
her walking out in tears excuse me shot
Angela says she doesn't know if she's
going to divorce Michael or not but
let's keep in mind his visa for the
United States can come in any day now so
she needs to make a decision quickly
oh what a moment Michael has played us
all
right next week is usman's turn in the
hot seat would you call him a scammer I
can call him a camera yeah I think who's
been Loki played out of my mom I am lost
if Usman pops back up on this show with
another American Woman
we will know the truth
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with ET because we are covering it
all I will see you next time
[Music]